we are incredibly honored to receive the  award  it is amazing to see the name of the  thousands of passionate people  who contributed to a film in the end  credit  while only a few of us stand here today  there are also thousands at asia that  come together  to bring our solution to users we humbly  accept this hour  on behalf of them as well as the  generation of innovators  before us just made it possible to  achieve our vision  at azo it is our mission to provide  creators  with a peace of mind that's what they  see on their screen  is true and precise it is our hope  that's what we accomplish today will  continue to facilitate growth  and inspire the future of technology for  years  to come thank you very much  you